foreign
2023 I'm Dave Rubin we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap that notification
Bell and today we've got a Reuben
report.locals.com Community Q a for you
uh but most importantly I hope that you
had a really lovely uh peaceful decent
family and food filled Easter weekend
for those who celebrate and if you
celebrate Passover I hope uh you enjoyed
your matzah and the story of Exodus and
all that good stuff we're going to start
Today's Show with a little bit from
Jordan Peterson's uh biblical lecture
series that he's doing on daily wire
plus uh talking about the significance
of Passover and exodus and creation I
thought that would be a nice way to
start this week uh post Passover what
we're actually technically still in the
middle of Passover but Post Easter and
then we will dive into a bunch of
questions from you guys and I will let
you in on a little secret technically we
did pre-tape this because I let my guys
go home for Easter but we will be back
live tomorrow I just blew up the whole
illusion holy cow before we get to any
of that let me talk to you guys about
Birch gold real quick you know inflation
has consequences and as the FED raises
interest rates to combat out of control
government spending long-term bonds have
diminished in value crippling banks
depositors are holding their breath in
investors are bailing on Bank stocks
diversification has never been more
important the recent surge in gold
prices is directly tied to the extreme
Market volatility right now this is why
gold has historically been a great hedge
against the stock market and against
inflation now would be a great time to
diversify into gold with Birch gold
group Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA and
precious metals here's what you need to
do visit birchgold.com Dave to get a
free info kit on gold
they'll help you to convert your
existing Ira or 401K that's tied to the
volatile Market into an IRA in Precious
Metals gold and silver and the best part
it's tax sheltered visit birchgold.com
Dave today to claim your free info kit
on gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is who you can trust
to protect your future visit
birchgold.com Dave today so I thought it
would be nice to do something sort of
related to the holidays right now and
Passover and Easter obviously and Jordan
Peterson is is pretty much the best when
it comes to translating these
old ancient texts into our modern
language and on The Daily wire plus he
has done a series of these biblical
lectures and these round tables
including a really fantastic group of
people Jonathan pajo my friend Dennis
Prager of course and a whole bunch of
other people biblical Scholars where
they dive into meaning they dive into
the difference between a literal
translation and a figurative translation
the importance the the push and pull in
how real or important this stuff really
is and I wanted to play a little bit of
the Roundtable them discussing Exodus
and well you just take a look yourself
why is it the Passover that becomes the
memorial in the foundation and is it the
sacrifice of the innocent and it's this
because it's the sacrifice of the Lambs
and the blood and so is the idea here
that the foundation of the proper state
is the voluntary sacrifice of the
innocent it's is that what's happening
no I don't think it's I don't think I
think that we need to see it really in
terms of of Egypt as
as opposites so you have the end of a
world Egypt ends God takes the seeds out
of Egypt
we have a new beginning which is also
based on sacrifice it's based on
voluntary sacrifice but that's the magic
of of the the Passover sacrifice it's as
if if you are willing to give your
firstborn to God God will give him back
to you that's the surprise okay so is it
founded on the principle of voluntary
sacrifice no you don't think so you
don't think so okay I think the plain
and obvious thing this was a night of
Liberation right I agree with it went
out right now but but there's also a
sacrificial element that's that's too in
the past of how it happened but the
basic thing and they remember it through
history Isn't it nice they were free to
say in our prayers
over and over
Justice for the Christian the the
crucifixion and Resurrection are the
central events I believe of Christian
theology
the central events of Jewish Theology
and I didn't make this up it is
constant in Jewish prayer
is creation and exodus so the reason I
wanted to play that clip and hopefully
uh you celebrated uh Easter or Passover
with family and friends and got to
retell the story of the crucifixion of
Jesus the Passover seder the importance
of leaving Egypt going to the holy and
the promised land all of that stuff but
I I thought the end there of what Dennis
said the importance of Exodus and
creation I thought really kind of
dovetails nicely with so much of what
we're going through right now as a
country so much of what I've been
talking about here is that we are sort
of it seems to me coming to the end of
something right like there's so many
people waking up we are coming to the
end of say the baby boomer Stranglehold
on everything this this gerontocracy
that has been in charge for so long we
are coming to the end of that right so
then there's the Exodus after that we
have to get on the other side of that
but it's not easy to just get on the
other side of that right the Hebrews
wandering around for 40 years before
making it to the promised land and we
now have to create something right
that's what I'm always talking about we
have to build new things we have to let
that thing go you know there were a lot
of a lot of Hebrews wandering the the
desert that were going can't we go back
to Egypt and then they created a golden
calf because they only knew slavery
we've only known One World in this
culture war that we're always fighting
and it's it's hard to blaze a new Trail
that's what Exodus is all about leaving
and then the creation of the new thing
we have to create new things whether
it's cultural institutions I don't think
we need new political institutions I
think we have to return to the original
intention of our political institutions
uh but we need new tech we need new
everything and uh dare I say despite the
fact that that was a table full of let's
say older white men there might be some
more insight that you can get into a
little bit of that so I just wanted to
offer you that little nugget before we
get to the Q a let me talk to you guys
about manscape and then we will get
right to it I think you're gonna like
this to read manscape is here with a
deal you can't pass over this Easter
season they've got the tools to give you
the beautifully decorated eggs of your
dreams just because it's Easter doesn't
mean it's okay to hide those bad boys
behind all that tall grass so make sure
your downstairs lawn is mowed get
yourself feeling as sweet as candy by
going to manscape.com and getting 20
percent off plus free shipping with code
Dave inside this ball care Bunny basket
you'll find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold on to
your goodies April's Easter but it's
also testicular cancer awareness month
manscape has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to testicular cancer Men's
Health and early cancer detection
manscaped is committed to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men 15 to 35 and giving
support for Fighters survivors and
families impacted by testicular cancer
as part of their we save balls
initiative save 20 off in free shipping
with the code David manscape.com that's
20 off and free shipping with code Dave
at manscaped.com hop into the best deal
of the year with manscaped and now back
to me Ruben report.locals.com Community
Q a here we go Elizabeth K says what do
you think about the latest push for
cbdc's Central Bank digital currency do
you believe this lame indictment is a
distraction for more Sinister policies
the Dems are going to try to push
through look this idea of a centralized
coin it's really quite bizarre if you
think about it
the whole idea of Bitcoin the whole idea
of cryptocurrency was that we would
decentralize Commerce right so because
these coins were not just on your
computer or in your wallet they are
decentralized right they're all over the
Internet and then you're able to trade
them and it has nothing to do with the
Federal Reserve it has nothing to do
with the US dollar or anything else it
can't be tracked by the government it's
it's a Libertarian Utopia but there's a
certain degree of irony in that the
United States government and by the way
many Western governments now want to
create their own coins and the problem
is if we were to all get on their coins
as opposed to coins that they could not
control so Bitcoin they cannot control I
have some Bitcoin let's say you have
something I want to buy a nice piece of
art whatever it might be I can send you
Bitcoin it's only it's peer to peer it's
you to me that's it right they want to
make Bitcoin faster that's that's a
whole other thing The Exchange is faster
and everything else uh but it's us doing
Commerce with each other has nothing to
do with the government taxes etc etc
once you have a centralized coin which
is what you're referring to then the
government can basically look at your
wallet and be like oh you bought that
from him you bought that from her you
sold this to that person and now their
hands are in everything and if you think
they don't tax that and just recreate
the whole racket that they have going on
right now uh well yes they will I hate
to tell you so do I think that the Trump
thing is a distraction from that I mean
I don't know that those things are fully
connected I think there's often things
that are somewhat distractions from more
nefarious plans but I am a hundred
percent for the idea of cryptocurrencies
particularly Bitcoin and decentralizing
as much Commerce and and everything
contracts they can do smart contracts
and a whole bunch more I love the idea
of decentralization the idea that the
government's going to come in and give
you a centralized coin it's just a
recreation of the problem we're trying
to get out of right now uh Tony says I
know you all are super busy but when is
the potential Florida meet up for those
of us who couldn't go and drink tequila
with you in the swamps of DC okay you
have my word we will do this middle to
to end of May we will do something in
Miami for sure we've been trying to it's
just been between the kids and traveling
and so much going on with the show and
I'm doing a million other things we just
really it has been hard but I got a
really cool spot that I'd love to get
some of you guys to we'll do it in May
it will just be for local subscribers so
stay tuned on that uh Mary says what do
you think of the idea of secession from
the blue states that keep putting in
such corrupt politicians how would this
work what would it look like is it our
only hope to get this country back look
if
if federalism would work as intended the
states the states would each be their
their little Laboratories of democracy
and they would have very little to do
with each other that is what we're
starting to see in some degree right so
a silver lining of covet is that we saw
that there was a stark difference it
just wasn't about taxes and that some
states don't have income tax and some
have very high income tax it was that
there were all sorts of differences on
policies related to lockdowns and
mandates and and everything else and
then what you started seeing was wow the
culture of these states is different the
people behave differently like the the
General State right now if you're in
California or or New York is is pretty
depressing it still is believe me I've
been back to both places like it's New
York feels like a zombie of New York I
don't have to tell you about the
craziness in in Cali obviously so look I
the question is what makes us United
we are this we can either just be the
States of America and it's like what
what is that what is what is the
connective tissue or were the United
States of America I would prefer that
the 250 plus year experiment that we've
been doing that has brought more Liberty
to more people than anything in the
history of the world I would prefer that
that continue but there really is a
problem and the blue states are not
going to stop and I keep telling you the
activists and the progressives and the
Machine and big Tech and the media it's
never going to stop right like there
isn't going to be a day when I'm going
to start doing the show and it's going
to be like oh you know you're not going
to believe this but on on CNN and the
view and MSNBC and all of the cultural
apparatus they're actually starting to
make sense like it's too late it's just
too late look what they've now done with
DeSantis the same thing that they're
doing with Trump right for years they
told you Trump was the worst thing ever
now they're moving on to Santa's on that
so it's like no matter how moderate our
guy is and he doesn't mean tweeting
anything they're always going to keep
moving
so I don't know what we do the problem
the inherent problem and I have I've
discussed this with a million people on
this show the inherent problem is that
if the red States I'm not talking about
secession but if the red States
basically were like we just want nothing
to do with you anymore
I don't know what that means exactly but
the blue States will not stop they will
not stop they will say this is where all
the racists and bigots are they will
demand that the federal government do
something about it God knows what they
would do with the army or who or just
who knows who knows so all I think you
can do within that is move to a place
that is in line roughly with your values
do the best you can to vote in the right
people and do do whatever you can do to
strengthen your local community that's
what I'm trying to do here and you know
on the margins if we can if we can get
better people in at the federal level
maybe we can fix some of this stuff but
I don't have hope that California is
going to turn around or New York is
going to turn around turn around or
something like that I just don't they've
made their choices after covet they've
reelected all of the same people
Gretchen Whitmer was re-elected in
Michigan it's like okay have at it but
don't try to take away our freedoms and
the problem is we want to separate from
them but they still want what we have
and that
that's just not tenable for a very very
long time Kyle says hey Dave when will
they add M to alphabet soup
lgbtqi plus I mean it's about sexual
preference when will they add in minor
attracted people maybe skip that and
just add the P for pedophile I mean the
whole thing is so stupid and it's like
if you're if you're a decent person who
happens to be gay you should want
nothing to do with this stuff I have
nothing to do with this stuff I don't
anyone that's my friend that happens to
be gay or lesbian has nothing to do with
this stuff this is a radical activist
group of people that are trying to undo
everything that was good you know from
what I remember and a lot of this was
before my time but the gay rights
movement was always about equality we
have marriage equality
and they should have stopped glad and
these organizations should have closed
up shop after equality wow we got
equality there are no laws
discriminating script discriminating
against people let's close up shop but
they can't close up shop right you got
to keep the non-profits going you got to
keep the the grift going in essence it
it goes from something just to something
that's a grift once you accomplish the
goal you accomplish a goal but then you
don't you don't want to tell people oh
you're out of a job so you ramp up the
insanity but this trans thing with what
it's doing to kids with what it's doing
to gay people because most of these kids
that they're converting into girls are
probably just gay boys or vice versa
it's so it's radically anti-gay it's
anti-child I would argue it's anti-human
because it's anti-truth it's messy it's
messy uh Richard says would you agree
that the announcement of RFK Jr that
he's running as president as a Democrat
will have a divisive impact on the
Democrat Party which could provide an
advantage to the Republican candidate I
believe RFK Jr will get Bernie screwed
by the Dems regardless of how he does in
the primaries but if he shows well will
he run as an independent the split the
split the vote opportunity that could
assure a republican Victory oh look so
first off I don't know what makes him a
Democrat anymore but let's just put that
aside he's decided to run as a Democrat
the the machine the DNC the Democrat
machine will do everything possible to
crush this guy they are never putting
him in a debate Joe Biden will not be
debating they will slander and destroy
this guy look Bernie was the guy with
the momentum last time really two times
ago and they and Hillary they cut the
deal they crushed him and now Bernie's
largely irrelevant which is kind of good
but it may have just delayed the
inevitable with these socialists anyway
but they will just ignore this guy
trying to destroy him lie about him blah
blah blah what would be interesting to
me I don't know what makes him a
Democrat so it's like why didn't you
just jump in on the Republican side
where you'll have some support because
he's so his main thing right now is
exposing fauci and the covid Machine
it's like you would get some people to
support you and then it's like wait we
could have Trump and DeSantis and Nikki
and Pompeo and vivec and RFK Jr and a
couple other people on that debate stage
that's a what a wide swath of
interesting people all with their own
kind of unique perspectives on things
and he would get on the debate stage
that's the key part he would get more
momentum so why he's doing it as a
Democrat
I don't fully understand maybe he feels
you know the Kennedy name is so
associated with the Democrat Party or
maybe he does it for a little while to
further expose how corrupt the Democrat
Party is and then he says hey even me as
a Kennedy I'm out that would be
something right I can't take this
anymore the Kennedys are out from the
Democrat Party that would that would
actually have have some weight to it uh
Oak says tell us about Passover at your
house how do you identify with the
Israelites escaping Egyptian slavery do
you use a book to guide your thinking
and immersion into history well I'm glad
you asked the question actually we did
the first night my sister and her
husband and three kids they had their
third child two weeks after we had
Justin so I've got a lot of babies
around here they live in Miami and we
did the uh seder at their house and it
was really lovely we used Dennis Prager
has written a hagata called Hagar is the
story of Passover that you read at the
table called the rational I think it's
called the rational hagata and it
basically there are quotes literally
from Jordan Peterson in there he does
what Dennis does which is just like a
very human way of explaining ancient
ideas and we went through that and then
we did some stuff for the kids and all
that and I would say what I said at the
top of the show the idea of Exodus and
creation is is deeply interesting to me
because I guess maybe humans are always
in it right like leaving something and
creating something new but I think we
are really really in it right now in
that the old world is coming to an end
it's clawing to to stay around and keep
attention and everyone look at it but
there's a new world being built whether
it brings us to that Bitcoin question
whether it brings us to New Media new
tech all of those things like that
actually is what the story is and it's
scary to get there right that's the
whole point that was the point of the
golden calf two they had they had been
wandering the desert and they still
wanted to worship something
we can get to that Promised Land I think
we can let's keep going uh David says do
you think any of this Trump indictment
will matter either way in the long run
unless something major changes the
Democrats already have all elections in
their pockets I'm just frustrated
because it's now obvious that we have no
that we no longer have equal justice so
it's not a stretch to apply this
inequality to elections also uh look
it's impossible to say what this is
going to do this Trump indictment and
the fact that they're not having another
hearing until December 4th like who
knows what is going to happen before
then you know it sounds like the first
debate will be in August so you know all
the candidates will basically have had
to have jumped in at that point is Trump
is this going to hamper his ability to
raise funds it seems like no so far he's
raising a lot of money right now you
know as I said in the last couple days
it's interesting because Trump announced
this candidacy for re-election in
September we had about three months of
quiet Trump he wasn't saying much there
was isn't a lot of momentum behind it
now they've reignited the momentum look
The X Factor in all of this obviously is
whether DeSantis gets in or not I think
there's every reason to think that he is
getting in I also think his window is
getting shorter because it's like at
some point where if everyone thinks
you're in and you're not saying it like
you can play that game for a certain
amount of time and then at some point
you can't play it so he has to make some
decisions on that and then we kind of
see where everybody else shakes out
um I don't know I don't know what the
machine is going to do to to take out
Trump I think the other part of this is
you know they may have really just
knocked Trump off his A-game here
because if you watch the speech at
Mar-A-Lago the night he got back from
New York from the hearing it was more
complaining Trump rather than attacking
Trump and even though I've been somewhat
frustrated with some of the attacks that
I think have been overboard Trump is at
his best when he's going on the offense
and going after the machine and joking
and being silly they could just bog him
down in Endless lawsuits he also has
this major thing coming out of Georgia
and he just may be so distracted it and
there may be just too much craziness
around it like you got to get good
people around you that that's one of my
other Arguments for DeSantis lately
which is I have met most of the people
in the operation right and it's like
these are good people they don't have
leaks there's a competency there and
everything else Trump has trouble
getting good people right that was one
of the things that even even the most
Ardent Trump supporter will tell you
that he had trouble Staffing during the
White House and and that's a real issue
so there's a lot of distractions here
and uh we shall see Florida man Chuck
says let's say we get past this madness
do you think the far left will just die
out or live in the darkness like the
remaining KKK members look they're never
going to fully go away and that is what
has been so dangerous about what these
progressives have done they have become
cult-like in their belief you cannot get
these people out of that cult you can
get a few to trickle out every now and
again but that's why we should always be
going for whatever is remaining of a
sane left and as much as I make fun of
these people there is a certain amount
of people like that it's why I always
say you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a Democrat my point to
these people is you can't be that you
don't have to just say you're a
republican you don't have to register as
a public but you probably if you care
about Freedom or any anything decent
and you dig America you got to start
voting for Republicans for now but yes
that thing if if you look at the the KKK
let's say as a cult-like organization
whatever's left of it whatever vestiges
are left of it wherever that is that's
what will hopefully be the ending for
these people I would just want them to
be pushed to the margins of society and
when some you know crazed drag queen
gets up there and starts lecturing how
they want to dance in front of children
everyone will be like haha no and and
then that would be it sorry that's not
what we do in a serious society that
that would be the the nice result of
this thing uh Buttercup says have Justin
and Luke had their first taste of wagyu
yet they have not had wagyu yet but
Justin is starting the uh the solid
foods he's doing the carrots he's doing
the avocado
um what else have we done you know you
got to like be very soft and and
gingerly with it and mush it we kind of
just mush it around give him a spoon
kind of let him do his thing you know it
can be a little nerve-wracking because
they'll kind of cough for just a second
and all that stuff so I think Luke will
be there probably in about a month but
they have not had wagyu yet but we do
have I got this sick wagyu rib eye that
we have been sitting on it's Frozen
right now it's just sitting in there
waiting and maybe I could maybe I could
just like dip his finger in a little
wagyu juice
Mike says who would win in a hooker
banging and crack smoking competition
Andrew Gilliam or Hunter Biden
would have been funny if there was just
no options there just like I have to
just pick generally speaking who would
win in such a uh look well Andrew
Gilliam for the record I don't think he
was smoking crack I think he was doing
meth uh Hunter Biden is more of a crack
guy it's a fine line between crack and
meth and that's your main takeaway for
the show today uh who would win in a
hooker banging was was Gilliam with
hookers I don't know if he was with
hookers I think he was just with some
friends oh they were hookers
they were male hookers okay so he was
with male hookers Hunter Biden likes
female hookers but who's to say what a
woman is really so and who's to say what
the difference between crack and meth is
next question Zionist says Dave let it
slip that he and the whole team are
coming to Israel in a few weeks when
will you be doing any shows here I
haven't seen anything advertised in the
Homeland yes so we are going to Israel
and Hungary uh I'm leaving on the 26th
my first day in Israel will be on the
27th the team's joining me on the 28th
we will be there until I believe May 5th
I've got an event at a conference at the
end which I'm sure we're going to get
some video on we're going to go to the
holy sites we're going to tour I'm going
to try to interview Bibi and a bunch of
other political leaders uh no one oh no
Brock on my team has been to Israel
before but the rest have not
so really want to just uh just go around
the country and and see it and
experience it and get some video out
there then in Hungary I'm doing a
conference and a talk I'm also going to
try to put on some live show in Israel
so yeah I will do some kind of meet up
for sure most likely in Tel Aviv we'll
do some kind of ticketed event at some
point and uh and just stay tuned more
more to come we're putting it together
right now uh Quinn says some wins in the
first quarter losses to begin the second
quarter seems like Dave's prediction of
2023 is already coming true setting up
for wins in the third quarter losses in
the fourthly with most election years
being a show how are you looking to
relax this non-election year well you
know I've been thinking about what I'm
going to do for Off the Grid August but
as I just mentioned I think the first
debate is in August and because I'm now
so close to all of this I don't know
that I want to sit that out I want to go
to all the debates I really do so I
don't want to give up that the portion
of time really like that month when I
don't have a phone and I don't know the
news and everything else like it I'm
telling you it has kept me sharp and
sane throughout this and it's good for
the brain it's good for the spirit it's
good physically like the whole thing I
also I really like the fact that my guys
get to take an extended period of time
off you know we we do put up content in
August that's what we did last year but
I always say to my guys it's how I say
on a day-to-day basis it's like you do
your work whenever you do it if you if
that means you don't have to work for
two weeks that's just great like as long
as everything gets done and amazingly no
one's let me down yet so uh so we're in
good shape on that front
um how do I stay sane
um
I like my big green egg I like to smoke
some food I like my tequila I like my
hot tub I like shooting Hoops pretty
much it so look it's it's going to ramp
up right like by August the crazy is
really going to ramp up and we're going
to be just in another election cycle it
just is what it is
but I would say as I often say on the
show it's like if I can do that maintain
my sense of humor not take it too
seriously but it is serious at moments
and and keep my door open so I can
interview as many of these people as
possible and we can keep fighting for a
Freer country that would be good
Brad says how has it been back how's it
been on the back end of locals and
rumbles since mug Club went live been
awesome seeing so many people making the
jump from YouTube to Crowder's show
which has been lights out since the
return so I'm sure most of you know this
already uh Crowder obviously uh he left
left the Blaze and then got into that
big freaking brouhaha with the daily
wire he ended up with us over here on
Rumble and the whole idea of Rumble and
locals is that we give you the platform
and the tools to do whatever you want we
can give you the tools to create a
subscription Network which is what what
I created with locals that Crowder now
uses for mug Club Rumble we don't care
what you say it's just you go out and
say it if you break the freaking law you
got a bigger problem than us so we were
there to just help him build a business
and I'm not allowed to tell you the
numbers I don't even know all the full
numbers but I think the the numbers that
were public last I heard within a day or
two of getting on Rumble and locals and
mug club and the whole thing he had
about 60 000 uh annual subscribers so
he's crushing it on there that's
Obviously good for the company it
provides other resources to do all sorts
of other things and there's just so much
good going on with Rumble I I just can't
overstate like how good this team is and
you know we've got the offices on the
west coast of Florida the rumble offices
we've got the locals Offices here in
Miami we're we're building we are
building those pipes they said build it
they said build your own internet we
said okay so uh much more to come but
I'm but I'm really thrilled the Crowders
part of this thing
um
crystal says how scared are you about
the country your boys will grow up in
I've been rather optimistic about things
of late but with this unprecedented
indictment of trump I really wonder if
we've Fallen too far down that slippery
slope to right this ship
you know I just it sounds corny but I
think you always have to have hope right
like you do and and this is bad like it
really is bad which is why I think I've
made it fairly obvious in the last week
I have no problem despite some of my
frustrations with Trump lately and the
fact that I do think it's Santa's time I
have no problem 100 no daylight airtight
defending Donald Trump over this this is
this is exactly what the machine does
this guy should not be in jail nor in
this nonsense ridiculous indictment
especially in a place with such
selective enforcement of the law like
New York City through this Alvin Brad
guy the D.A the Soros funded D.A
um but I do have hope I do have hope
because look if this is the best of the
best if Joe Biden and AOC and these
clowns if these are the best of the best
we're fighting they're not that great
and maybe you know the depressing part I
guess would maybe be that the United
States that you know I always say let's
go back to 1995. maybe that thing can
never come back right it may be a can
and that could be a function of Time
Marches On and how technology changes us
and the changing of the media
and and just everything about our modern
world maybe we can't get back to that
but at the state level I think we can
and that's why I always say that I mean
the funny thing and part of the reason
I'm able to do this show and not go
crazy my day-to-day life
in my home in in the city that I live in
in the state that I live in is pretty
damn good then I wake up in the morning
and I got to look at the news and I go
man there's a lot of crazy nonsense
coming out of DC and that's a freaking
corrupt place and everything else but
I'll also tell you look a couple weeks
ago we went to DC and I saw a crop of
Republicans we've posted all of the
interviews a crop of Republicans that
was pretty darn good and and trying to
trying to limit the state and and fix
things so there's always hope you gotta
have hope and when it comes to the kids
yeah I mean as I said before it just it
just instills in me that I have double
triple quadruple eight times the reason
to fight right because it's on me like I
as someone that I guess has a tiny bit
of influence in any of this my my duty
is doubly incumbent that I better fight
for the right things so that these kids
can have at least as good a life as I
had uh one more for you Amy Says which
interview in DC did you enjoy the most
you don't have to say the the McCarthy
one because we did it live with so many
of you from locals about 100 of you in
then we took the tours and there was a
certain energy in the room and it was
fun to walk through the capitol with
McCarthy the the house leader and all
that that was that was awesome to one
degree the one that I probably enjoyed
the most was I had never met my
congresswoman Maria Salazar I had never
met her before but she's our
congresswoman here in Miami and she was
just a ball of energy and joy and and
she loves America and she at the end I
just I basically I don't think I ended
it properly I just kind of turned to the
camera and I was like man that was easy
because she just was just so overflowing
with uh with joy and and goodness and I
believe that interview is up already
right they're they're all up as of today
I think JD Vance will go up today Monday
and uh I believe the Salazar interview
went up on Friday and uh yeah just stuff
is happening as they say uh guys if you
want to join us for the next q a
reubenreport.locals.com we leave you
with a crying AOC there's no post game
show today but we will be back live at
11 A.M Eastern tomorrow
goodbye murdered because you're alive
and you're basically intact you weren't
murdered buddy
[Applause]
you were murdered